il toro si è ingroppato Ashley Ma stai
fermo ma possibile oh oh
Ma che cazzo è Oh grazie Ma ti pare
Ah bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio di Resident Eagles
che facciamo Siamo qua
ho chiesto io un secondo prima tuo padre
si fida di me
e devi fidarti anche tu fai quello che
ti dico
ti riporterò a casa
io
Io
me ne andrei poi fate voi
[Musica]
Bene bene
Ma questi stanno già salendo Oh merda
via via via via via via via via via
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce
Ah ecco chi era Ma sapete che non
pensavo pensavo fosse quella super sexy
ma aveva salvato dalla finestra che
pensavo fosse lei il secondo con cui
fare le cose in due non escile non
ricordavo Ok Tirala anche sulla scala
già che ci siamo visto che non ci
raggiungono così
Oh ma siamo bloccati aspetta una cosa
alla volta non sto capendo Non iniziare
a mettermi le ansie già m'hai cacato u
cazz in un minuto che stiamo per mini
adesive esclusive sinistra possono
essere montati sulle Frecce equipaggio
L3 mentre mi dicono il lancia frecce Ah
dalla finestra perfetto
buttati tanto bravissimo non gliene
frega niente di lei
No no stai là tranquilla Ti prego
Chi non si farebbe prendere le braccia
di questo questo Adone biondone
incredibile fidati 10 su 10 se non la
prende la lascia schiantare
per terra a caso così Peccato Ciao Ho
sperato un po'
c'è la tensione qua eh O di Però andiamo
avanti prego è nata assorbente andiamo
avanti ragazzi Minchia ho fatto un salto
più la più in alto di quello che dovevi
fare tu prima reale
c'è gente non parlate al telefono adesso
adesso ragazzi entrano una nuova
dinamica di gioco che è questa io devo
giocare e far fuori la gente sapendo che
c'è Sta stronza indietro che vi dico
proviamolo il tacco Stealth per iniziare
poi vediamo
è uno ok
Ma sono tutti dentro
Oh merda
ok Stai zitta
stami dietro e basta che qua è un casino
Oh merda
la luce è durata un secondo Orca [__]
attenzione che male abbiamo iniziato da
un secondo e un attimo
che cazzo quanti siete
doppia quella dietro l'ho preso
Ok uh eh vabbè ragazzi
Ma [__]
Eh ragazzi ma sono troppi Cioè non è che
posso fa' tutto io e qua Aspetta Mori
Ok ragazzi allora facciamo così perfetto
Ma ragazzi ma è incredibile ma quanti
cazzo sono
ecco beh è andata bene Comunque mi
sembra
arrivo Ashley sono qua eh Salve Beh Che
ne dici Ah no c'è ancora un tizio
Ok a posto
teoricamente ho risolto esci è stato un
po' complesso ma vabbè
Ascolta lo zio Io lascerei perdere
questa cosa da poco le cose Ok perfetto
niente male che cazzo è al vento Minchia
ci manca solo questo non funzioni
pistola per 10 vamos sei contenta esci e
vai ancora un'altra Quest si occupi del
cane Selvaggio che sta bloccandomi il
villaggio capisci addirittura
no cammina Ecco io sono stato molto meno
meno gentile Lo so però me ne fotto
Let's go a qua siamo proprio nel
villaggio in tutto questo Beh certo
Ok
come cazzo è il cane del villaggio
scusate
Ok Madonna ragazzi è pieno di gente già
sento ci manca solo questo
ok
perfetto
fuori merda
Meno male che il caricatore aumentato
ragazzi
ok
non fare un cazzo esci stai qua
tranquilla
la merda adesso cosa si è trasformata
attenzione
Vabbè dai è andata male Madonna quanti
siete raga
Boh è successo un casino senza volere
però
ok
è morta mais
Vabbè dai Sono stato bravo Ah qua ci
entro con lei Ah me la ricordo sta roba
Eccolo vedi che mi è servita Ashley in
qualche modo Minchia un'utilità ce l'ha
'sta tizia una mi permette di
raggiungere posti che non potevo
raggiungere prima dai Apri veloce quanto
tempo
ma chi è che sta parlando Ok grazie
sai che c'è qua dentro
bracciale elegante Nais mi servirebbero
le gemme ragazzi perché non le trovo più
Rubini ste cose esci di cose Seguimi Non
fare cazzate che giocate qua
teoricamente dovrebbe essere ma dovremmo
mancare poco per l'estrazione proprio lì
minchia minchia
siamo veramente vicini ovviamente andrà
qualcosa storto perché non può essere
Però non è un incubo però di essere
contenta che son qua invece di farmi o
no dai Vi prego che palle Che [__]
lo dici a tuo padre oh attenzione
attenzione
devi stare lontana ti prego
Comunque è fortissimo Vabbè scegliere la
Red Nova è stata la è stata la scelta
ragazzi del gioco proprio Number One
perfetto Minchia mi ricordo che qua ho
fatto un casino
con tizio con la testa de cazzo Ok
perfetto c'ho la testata bue
ah ah attenta stai ferma esci e vai via
dalla Vai Via Vai via Vai Via Vai via
via via
very nice me la sto giocando ragazzi la
pistola È incredibile Scusatemi ho fatto
la scelta sento Un ruggito un po' troppo
grosso c'è il Mercante lì c'è un mercato
Porca [__] di nuovo ma ancora ma
basta
Ok aspetta aspetta aspetta perfetto
Dai muori prima era morto molto molto
prima merda
è morto è morto perfetto
perfetto che giocata ragazzi attenzione
questo per terra attenzione questo per
terra perfetto occhio
c'è il toro che sta facendo cazzi tuoi
praticamente
Smeraldo Nice che cazzo è successo
il toro si è ingroppato ma stai fermo
faccia de cazzo
ma possibile oh oh oh
ma che cazzo è Oh ma ti pare
scoccia [__] Ma te lo giuro guarda ma
vattene a [__] Mori Lancia una
granata frammentazione non posso perché
c'è Ashley non posso
Ma vattene a [__] va' Ma non ho
capito nemico number one di
residentivole il bue che stava qua non
ne serviva niente povero cristo Ah tra
l'altro se non erro qua Cioè vedi che
c'è Infatti me lo ricordavo Cioè cosa
che posso piccare la chiave attenzione
e testa di gufo Antica pipa mi sembra un
gufo
un'antica pipa vuoi pippare per caso no
chiedo allora andiamo via ragazzi siamo
qua Questo è il punto di estrazione che
che
[Applauso]
Giovanni Come si chiama lo zio amico
corri corri corri corri e infatti c'è
gente la vedo Ice
questa dove cazzo è uscito dove era
finito dove eravate prima tutti quanti
anche quell'altra che mi ha salvato la
finestra
ma questa è dell'ambrella per quello ce
l'ha con lui
state tutti calmi comunque
abbiamo tutti
adesso L'importante non è questo e ti ha
salvato il culo
Ma ti ha salvato il culo lascialo stare
povero cristo
devo fare questa cosa non me la ricordo
la devo fare io sul serio è una
cinematica
mi sa che dovrò combattere ragazzi sarà
molto interessante
se moriamo Lei rimarrà sepolta là per
tutta la vita però Vabbè dai meglio che
se l'è presa dei mostri Ok
divertiamoci io non ho così tanti colpi
lo zio Cioè non è che posso
Cosa posso usare ricevi munizioni
va bene Ah posso Posso Ah minchia posso
sbarrare le porte Vai vai Togliti uno
di roba per sparare
il piacere di quanta roba c'è
ok
praticamente li dovrei tenere fuori
dalla finestra però me ne fotto
Ok
è fratello guarda che mi devi dare una
mano perché io non è che posso fa tutto
io qua Aspetta che bravo Vabbè dai Meno
utile
ragazzi Io so già che finirò tutti i
colpi quindi fratello mi devi dare
Madonna che culo Occhio a quello per
terra si alza si è alzato
3 perfettoia Ahia che male non mi ha
fatto che io con una botta così
Praticamente dovresti morire tantissimo
ho sbagliato Arno ho sbagliato Arno
Vabbè allora quando sono in tanti
teoricamente questo dovrebbe servire
[Applauso]
teoricamente poi non lo so
perfetto perfetto
Vai col calcione
perfetto
mirato colpo allegria Macarena occhio
Madonna ragazzi quanti cazzo sono
fratello devi stare attento Qua c'è
qualcosa Ah no mica risorse del
Porca [__] Meno male che mi è venuto
davanti perché se non fosse stato per
quello non avrei colpito mai con la mia
Mira di merda che c'ho provato Ragazzi
io faccio quello Madonna quanti cazzo
sono fuori sto male
vabbè Stai attento col cazzo se non mi
dà una mano allora un attimo che qua la
vedo grigissima non ho Cure posso solo
combinare queste cose qua Vabbè
combiniamole che ti devo dire
perfetto
ragazzi Orca [__] Io andrei al piano di
sopra ma sopra vedete che succede Ti
lascio qua Giovanni
minchia
perché almeno prendi tempo
meno che qualcuno non sia già salendo ma
mica sono già saliti tutti
praticamente da qua non dovrebbero
arrivare poi non lo so Eh porca di
quella [__]
chi cazzo sono No vabbè ma è terribile
pure
Oddio attento che esplode
Vabbè che è successo posso uscire posso
scendere da qua
non posso scendere Va bene
raga sto usando il pompa perché non
faccio il tempo a equipaggiare altre
armi che mi fanno fuori praticamente
tavola di legno l'ho trovata adesso Beh
è utile quando sono entrati già tutti
basta colpiscilo Cristo
ma puoi un po' ne ho fatti fuori eh non
sono Non basterà mai ma non lo so
c'è una scala qua
Che cazzo fai questo è scemo
Maurizio
Bene
benissimo va bene Oh finalmente arriva
anche la gente dal piano di sopra mi
mancava questa eh mi mancava mi serve no
madonna quanti cazzo sono Aspetta un
attimo Allora facciamo così guarda Uno
e due va teoricamente un po' è servito
io vado di sotto ci vediamo
[Musica]
praticamente Se cambiamo Ma vedi che
volendo poi barricare di sotto aspetta
è pari a Bari cavarica di sotto Perfetto
ce n'è un'altra Allora teoricamente le
finestre le posso togliere tutte
Ok
così almeno dalle finestre non arrivano
arrivano solo di sopra che non è male
prima vista la situazione Ok Qua devo
caricare posso usare una granata non è
male per una volta
ok
boh
non lo uso mai
Pure
minchia ci mancava lo zio
uno teoricamente con cinque colpi dovrei
farlo fuori
quattro quattro
bastato Eh è morto Meno male
ok
Mica sto morendola
dove cazzo è uscita
da dove cazzo è uscita ma non era dentro
il coso
Ma che cazzo fa
Ma io ero convinto che fosse tipo dentro
l'armadio Che cazzo aveva fatto prima Ah
aveva fatto uscire Boh Non ho capito
cosa è successo però Vabbè fa niente
L'importante è avercela fatta è più o
meno
ho lasciato un po' Meno male che ho
raccolto le cose per terra perché non
solo avrei lasciato tutto là che culo
e niente t'hanno iniettato un po' di
cosa ma tachiperina e via la prima volta
Beh non è proprio un buon segno a
prescindere
il sangue sono causati da una cosa
chiamata
Beh Dentro di te c'è la stessa cosa beh
grazie La cosa che mi ha resi così
veramente un bel una bella notizia
Quello che ti succede questi sintomi
non voglio diventare come loro ma tu sei
fortunata Vedi A questo stadio il
parassita La Placa può essere ancora
rimosso con un'operazione chirurgica ti
serve solo sapere come a lui lo sa
Ahia vuol dire che lui l'ha fatto quindi
non potete tirargli testate
adesso Il tempo scorre perché ci aiuti
perché mi fa sentire meglio mettiamola
così
Mi faccio vivo io Va bene facciamoci il
cazzo l'estrazione Non servirà proprio
cioè alla fine non veniamo estratti per
niente fine capitolo gli essa finiamo
anche il 5 ragazzi molto figo comunque
questa era il 5 quindi il prossimo è il
6 inizio del capitolo 6 Madonna
ho fatto i culetti e Madonna stavo Ero
lì lì per schiattare tutte le volte ma
non è mai successo eh
l'accendino stavo solo le chiavi della
macchina stasera Ciao La macchina
questo non me la conta giusta Hai una
sigaretta
e la gnocca di prima
si conoscono
Ada Wong
dovresti proprio complimentarti per il
mio ottimo lavoro mi sono fatto il culo
e sono riuscito a nasconderla prima di
essere preso
ed è per questo che sono ancora vivo
l'accordo era ti tiriamo fuori di qui
quando consegni l'Ambra niente Ambra
niente protezione Luis
quanto sei puntigliosa eh
va bene
vado a prenderla ora che dici
Madonna che gnocca ragazzi è veramente
incredibile nulla a che vedere con come
si chiamava
Come si chiamava a Claire Claire di
Resident Evil 2 però però
se vogliamo essere proprio sinceri Bene
bene
Fammi indovinare la tempesta è troppa
ecco
no ci ammazziamo dobbiamo fare questo
andremo a cercare un posto più sicuro
non hai fatto un cazzo finora quindi
figurati Torneremo a nuoto se necessario
andiamo a nuoto in America dalla Spagna
cazzo sei Cristoforo Colombo
e non lo so Ashley però nel dubbio non
morire perché sono perdo fuggi dal
villaggio dove andare mettivi intermedio
Vabbè allora My Boy Se questa è la porta
per andare avanti teoricamente Adesso
dovremmo compagnia
ce la faccio ce la faccio Ciao arrivo
Ciao arrivo Ciao arrivo Ciao arrivo Ciao
arrivo Ciao arrivo
yes come on
non mi ricordo sei nel gioco originale
c'era l'uccisione sterzo Secondo me no
L'hanno aggiunta qua Comunque vabbè sti
cazzi
Ok Che cazzo è successo Oh ma chi è
Ah ma hanno sparato proprio stai teste
di culo Oh andate a fuoco occhio
Madonna occhio Ahia che male
via via via via via via via via via via
via via fatto anche un metro
merda Questa è uscito
Minchia glielo attaccata allo zio
un cazzo Si può aprire la porta qua via
via via
attenzione zio perfetto Secondo me è
morto adesso non è morto Porca [__]
Quanto regge sto tizio se ne va ha
deciso che per lui basta così va bene
Sto usando le frecce perché non le uso
mai ragazzi Almeno cerco di non sprecare
tutti i colpi ok
Dai
perfetto ancora una
e morirai prima o poi oh è morto cioè
sono voluti 62 colpi però è morto
ok
molto bene
Scusa allora le frecce non sono male
secondo me c'è di meglio più avanti e
più vedo costruzioni così e mi sembra
sempre più difficile quindi sta roba un
po'
Qua mi sembra una Rena ragazzi Io non
vorrei ribeccare il tipo di prima quindi
se possiamo merda
non era corto mai
perfetto pure
Ok
cos'è che c'è Calice dell'espiazione
è diventato il banco dei pugni sto gioco
devo vendere più roba che cioè vendo più
roba che proiettili che sparo
praticamente non so dove sto andando
ragazzi cioè vado al naso qui è
tranquilla sì sì
qua dentro Vai Metti ti Mettiti intanto
non serve un cazzo fighissimo
Per quanto mi riguarda uh
Eh vabbè cazzo sei oh grandioso Bastava
fare un passo indietro comunque Eh
madonna rugby 2 bene questa è una gran
notizia Aspetta che devo capire che arma
mi conviene usare di più non sapevo
Secondo me la granata frammentazione e
devo sparare tipo tre lo proviamo uno
Ok proviamo con la seconda
c'è pure gente Porca [__] manca solo
quello 3
i 4 Vabbè qualcosa Li avrò fatto queste
cose Spero
Io me ne andrei
Là tipo Porca [__]
Ok ma mi faccio un giro eh Ragazzi io mi
faccio un giro Vediamo che succede
Comunque non è stato non è il massimo
che mi spuntino sempre i tizi con la
motosega salta su due Tra l'altro Ok
guarda lì che casino
eh Però ragazzi cioè non è che posso fa
tutto io qua Eh aspetta
va bene è morta non muore non muore mai
che cazzo devo fare io con questi con la
motosega ragazzi Scusatemi che devo fare
Che devo fa ditemelo
come li faccio fuori questi qua motosega
non si possono
fare allora attaccaci la mina Togliti
ma non a lui [__] Vabbè dai uguale
ok
cioè vedo che comunque fanno danno si
fanno danno anche da soli eh quelle con
le motosega Ok ok non è male che cazzo
succede lì
[Musica]
ok
ok no che non posso colpirla perché c'è
il tizio e vai giù vai giù
Meno male che si ammazzano da soli
ragazzi e muori Che palle è morta
non so come è morta
è morta
Minchia
Madonna che casino ragazzi Ok ok
sono morti tutti e ce l'ho fatta a
manovella tutto sto casino nella porta
ecco cos'era quell'oggetto lì ma è tutto
sto casino tutto a posto Esci e c'è
stata una breve colluttazione ora che ho
la manovella teoricamente posso passare
di qua perfetto
Anche i meccanici all'occorrenza
pescatori tutto siamo a posto devo
aprire io Minchia che poi chiave
Mi sa che sei abituata a scappare dai
matti
è un complimento tutto sto casino
bene andiamo
ancora questo che intanto Com'è che non
lo sentiamo mai arrivare gigantesco e
sarà la sessantesima volta ai tipi di un
cartone così da qui Ashley via
Richiedei
ruba un motorino e scappa cioè proprio
rubato
esley e via via via via via via via via
via fuori le palle Ma gli devo sparare a
'sto zio io io non gli sparerei via via
via via fuori Fuori fuori fuori le palle
via l'ho detto io dovete stare fermi in
un punto e basta Cioè Invece di far sto
casino
Eh vabbè dai fa niente mi piglio le male
accettate basta che corri Uh buono buono
buono buono buono buono buono lì mi
piace mi piace perfetto e posso curarmi
Già che ci sono Anzi posso anche curarmi
con il coso che ovviamente la vita
quindi Nice
occhio occhio non ti fare incapacitare
Ashley Perché
Fa niente fa niente Fa niente fa niente
Fa niente fa niente tutti i giorni mi
capitano queste cose
Ok allora niente
perfetto mica ho fatto un disastro merda
no esce di capacità no merdaccia di
merda
è difficilissimo
è difficilissimo Vabbè dai ci riproviamo
Ok ok
no tutto ok un cazzo
dobbiamo andare
avete un paracadute ragazzi
Porca [__]
pensavo che adesso non sono caduti va
Meno male
cioè prima sono morto per un nulla
Ciao zio Ci vediamo domani lo so stesso
posto stessa ora tanto questo qua si
compare dal niente dal nulla cosmico
esce dal terreno non si capisce che non
si capisce come cazzo fa non lo capisco
sto tizio però vabbè ma varione
c'è il Mercante Ma dove minchia sia
finito
Ok va bene
Salve buongiorno Ho un sacco di roba da
venderti lo zio guarda Uno e due anzi
anche le lacrime e il fermaglio ok e ho
91.000 volendo posso comprare il
lanciarazzi io posso comprarlo ma non ho
spazio per comprarmi Ah perché è enorme
giustamente
credo che sta roba shotti cioè c'è un
boss che non riesco a fare lo uso e lo
shotto Però vabbè Ah vedi qua Ah c'è il
calcio per la Red 9 [__] vacca come
mi serve e allora ragazzi andiamo avanti
perché teoricamente Ho semplicemente
comprato un po' di roba ma alla fine ho
fatto un po' di di acquisti di munizioni
e robe Ma ancora
Credo che qua sarò nella merda Però
questa pene er pelato nasconditi la zia
bravo
Bravo è servito è servito è morto è
morto è fatta è fatta è fatta e alla
frutta
abbandona il
al volere del nostro non non è proprio
la cosa
per me non serve un cazzo
di schiacciare i tuoi nemici secondo me
questa cosa avrà a buon fine
ma è la bossfight quindi devo far fuori
sto stronzo Ecco bravo
Porca [__] che schifo ragazzi Non me la
ricordavo star Madonna ma è terribile
Mendez si chiama sto tipo secondo me vai
dai proviamo questo
bene
è finita già male non è neanche partita
già sto morendo Allora aspetta un attimo
Ma io posso schivare in questo gioco in
qualche maniera normale
Porca [__] che schifo No vabbè ragazzi
tipo intanto Sembra anche abbastanza
fragile però non lo è per niente
vedi che col tasto cerchio mi fa
schivare le cose ma non me le fa
schivare proprio tutte
Ok ottimo ricaricare adesso Ah posso
andare anche di sopra c'è la scaletta Ok
una volta l'ho schivato vai vai vai vai
sopra
Madonna raga Che schifo
Beh io ti sparo con la pistolina poi non
so che succede
all'occhio minchia
Non male raga secondo me non male Non
male Non male Non male Non male Non male
poteva andare peggio Allora prima la
granatina uh
la granatella
vai
Eh fa male questa teoricamente poi
vediamo non so Prova prova di nuovo
benissimo le granate a frequentazione
servono eh Ragazzi comunque partite è
morto Ho vinto
scherzavo Non diciamo cazzate prima
rie Infatti lo sapevo devo riaffrontare
a ritorno Vabbè
però la metà di sotto le l'ho staccata
fare qualcosa a
quanto pare
Urca [__] sta lanciando le cose
benissimo esattamente quello che non
doveva succedere Aspe che mi devo curare
Beh però non sta andando troppo male
Praticamente posso ricaricare le armi
nel mentre nella merda
manca
spara gli spara gli Sparagli che in
questo momento serve
merda
ok
Stai fermo
Tutto a posto Tutto a posto sono
abituato a queste cose
Sto tornando pure a fuoco come ci
mancava solo quello Guarda
che sei Goku posso curarmi di nuovo Beh
non ho tantissime cure effettivamente
Ok ok
teoricamente se faccio così lo butto giù
però
ce l'ho fatta
ma veramente
pensavo durasse di più Ragazzi ve lo
giuro pensavo di essere di più
Meno male
l'occhio me lo piglio lo vendo tanto in
tanto Ashley che si fa i cazzi sua mo
passa qualcuno la rapisce
Brava brava
non ce n'era bisogno potevo uscire Io
con una arrotolata da lì però vabbè
ok
occhio finto di mente cioè
Eccoci qua perfetto Beh andata bene
raga' ricordavo
Non me la ricordavo sinceramente
a prescindere Non è durato tantissimo
Sarà che un potenziato parecchio le armi
con questa Red nuova incredibile
Ah grazie Sei stata bravissima ha fatto
tutto tu
Vabbè dai ma in tutto questo il Mercante
che era rimasto fuori Mi hai fregato un
cazzo
va bene ed è morto lo spingone Almeno
quello che ovviamente non è il boss
finale il castello
Ma siamo già alla parte del Castello
ragazzi no che mi arrivano tutti che
corrono e io mi chiudo dentro il
castello ho sperato sta cosa No non c'è
Ah ecco
Se volete il castello raga che la parte
del Castello me la ricordavo molto più
avanti invece no cazzate Ah forse non è
quel che forse ci sono due parti del
Castello Ok vai basta spoilerare perché
non conoscere Resident Eagle la smetto
che non ci seguiranno perfetto
Raga non so se è questa la parte che
dico io ma è bella incazzata Comunque ve
lo dico Capito terminato e quindi
ragazzi anche l'episodio di Giuly è
finito e ci vediamo al prossimo episodio
Fatemi sapere nei commenti che cosa ne
pensate lasciate un bel commento e un mi
piace su che cosa ne pensate appunto del
gioco lasciate un bel commento per forza
scrivete cose costruttive anche su come
migliorare armamenti cose robe Io c'ho
tutte le mie idee Ma fatemi sapere le
vostre E noi come sempre ci vediamo ad
un prossimo video bella ragazzi